cracked Studios locked themselves inside
a house with a special guest the house
in Nashville the guest cinemasins
the goal to make as many sketches as
possible this is one of them well for
starters your resume was great yeah
you've developed quite a reputation on
paper if you want to work here we need
know you can cut it I'm just excited
about the challenge okay then I believe
Devon sent you the script that you were
supposed to read so tell us how you make
these scripts right for our network good
let's yeah let's start this first one
it's called true faith honestly I feel
like this one is ready it's one of the
best scripts I've ever read it's about
this nun named sister Christine right
yeah this is a strong one you were right
to latch on with this one the whole cast
is nuns well there's a priest dark
complicated priest standard priest he's
really the moral center of the show but
it's set in a comment so everyone's
really the moral Center huh everyone's
so positive it just feels kind of flat
kind of saying okay we can make the
priest complicated right I don't know
you tell me I mean it's not gonna break
the show if we give the priest a little
edge maybe he's got a past a troubled
one this is getting closer okay yeah so
he's got a dark past but you can still
sense if there's some good in him right
yeah he's not a villain but he's not a
hero either
ah not a hero sort of more like in like
a okay man tae-woo that is your idea and
it is a good one I must say this dark
brooding drug-dealing also your idea
antihero priest huh
well my only problem does this seem a
little AMC yeah it doesn't scream HBO
and only HBO just yet is there maybe you
think something HBO could offer the
other networks well I mean there's
nudity but I don't think nuns have a lot
of sex was a shower I bet I bet they
shout out all the time those nuns these
are good clean pure women you're gonna
wanna make that clear with a shower
scene or two per episode sure they
shower or bathe together I read that in
a book I read somewhere a communal the
characters will be like oh yeah my tits
are out right now so what characters
don't think anything about it why they
leave him out so long okay I guess I
could see that I just
it all seems a little a little not TV
great and that is exactly what we not
are I can see the trailer now promises
of nudity forlorn looks off into the
distance
darker cover of REM is losing my
religion whoo faith healing and drug
dealing is greenlit let's get Josh
pullin two stars the priest he's due for
an HBO show right yeah definitely okay
what's next uh uh well there's this
great script about Thomas Jefferson
murdering and selling drugs to
supporting his secret African family I
love it you know there is evidence that
he grew and used him which is like mad a
drug like Beth
this is HBO guys we just want to show
Thomas Jefferson the real person you
know like John Adams or Deadwood you
we're not scared to teach or show
America at her worst as long as it's
honest also Charlize Theron is gonna
play Martha Jefferson but she's gonna do
it is like a part lesbian it's not
negotiable and don't forget your idea
for the hemp and meth angle good idea
next okay uh all right this one honestly
I don't think it can work at all it's
just Animal Farm as a show
so I mean True Blood just started out as
an adaptation of Ulysses still Jackson
here but the old HBO spin on it
Leopold sucking I think I honored the
source material okay oh well the
Napoleon Pig is already kind of an
antihero so loved it greenlit lose the
pigs though and swap now for some sexy
mermaid lesbians that go on land
sometimes scores a trailer to a cover of
that REM song that's about a pig
rebellion which one is that you are on a
roll kid Devon did you get all that
biggest thumbs up from Devon that did
not hurt six feet under ratings at all
okay
I'm sorry is it absolutely necessary
that every single HBO show has to cram
in some violence and sex and darkness
Treme doesn't do that doesn't it I swear
I am going to watch Treme I'm going to
watch it this is literally the first
time I've heard that word did we really
do a whole XP ocean without violence
news yes maybe I don't
it's I haven't watched the whole thing
yeah obviously yet it's the show it's
about that the star is the city and the
music it plays such an important role in
the narrative I have it TiVoed I haven't
watched the whole thing yet I'm going to
it's just every time I try end up
watching Game of Thrones again
you